When we imagine lunar colonies, they mimic
cities in a small scale and have sweeping
vistas that include the Earth hanging above
the horizon.
But that’s a great way to get cancer super
fast since we still don’t know how to protect
ourselves from cosmic radiation.
So one solution might be to eschew scenic
surface colonies in favor of lovely lava tubes.
Lava tubes on the Moon are basically the same
as the ones we see here on Earth.
Back in the Moon’s history when it was geologically
active, molten rock flowed over the surface.
The outside layer cooled first while the inside
kept flowing.
But once the Moon’s internal lava flow ceased,
left behind were these huge hollow passages.
And because the Moon has relatively lower
gravity, it’s possible that these lava tubes
could have high ceilings, perhaps large enough
to allow a city to be erected inside them.
YEAH.
MOON CAVES.
We can find these caves by looking for pits
or “skylights.”
And JAXA scientists did just that, as did
NASA scientists using the Lunar Reconnaissance
Orbiter.
Japan’s Lunar Radar Sounder looked at the
area close to the Marius Hills Hole, and found
these skylights might lead to lava tubes.
Radar data shows a distinctive echo pattern
of a loss of power followed by a peak, suggesting
there might be a hollow underground lava tube
in the area around these skylights.
This would be great for astronauts!
The tube’s thick roof would be a natural
shield against cosmic and solar radiation,
meteor impacts, and the Moon’s extreme temperatures.
It’s even possible that these tubes, with
the end opening properly sealed with an airlock,
could be pressurized with oxygen to create
a breathable habitat.
Yay, no space cancer!
That is a far more appealing prospect than
living in tiny modules that, frankly, wouldn’t
offer nearly as much protection from all of
these hazards.
Of course Newt can’t move there yet.
Scientists need to study the area more with
better instruments to really figure out how
big these potential underground tubes might
be, BUT the preliminary evidence all points
to these natural structures offering at least
some inherent protection.
Not to mention this simplifies access to safe
spaces on the Moon, and could come with the
added bonus of giving researchers access to
geologically significant sites that have so
far been out of reach.
Moon caves, FTW!
Whether or not we’ll have wifi access in
those caves isn’t clear yet, but just in
case, why not set up your lunar exploration
website now!
When you buy a domain name from Domain.com,
you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a.com or .net domain name.
Get 20% off Domain.com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
For more science in your day, be sure to subscribe
to Seeker, and if you want to know whether
we can just create an atmosphere on the Moon,
I’ve got some answers right here.
But speaking of, the Moon actually has an
atmosphere, though it’s so minor it properly
speaking an exosphere.